All right, what's up guys? I'm going to
go over how you can scalp NQ using VWOP
or in this case I like refer to this as
DVA which stands for developing value
area because that's the way I like to
trade VWAP personally. So, uh this is
NQ. Like I said, you can do this on any
market. It doesn't matter. I trade lots
of markets. Um many people within the
server trade lots of markets. It really
doesn't matter. Um the concepts and the
way to read things are all exactly the
same. So, to start things off, if you're
not familiar, VWAP is volume weighted
average price, right?
um indicate what you know what you'd
call your value area is standard
deviations from the mean right so the
mean being VWOP or in you know other
instance in regards to a profile whether
this is TPL or this is volume profile or
you have the mean which is the point of
control and then one standard deviation
either side of the mean is going to give
you your value area so value area high
value area low. So same same thing can
be said about VWOP here. So VWOP is the
mean one standard deviation um either
side of the mean here is going to give
you value area. So value area low, value
area high and then we have the
rotational extreme is what I like to
call these. So it's two standard
deviations from the mean. Okay. Uh and a
lot of people get this wrong. This is a
really common misconception which we'll
get into kind of the basic ways you can
actually trade off of this. Um a lot of
people are always trying to trade off of
the second standard deviation. That's
just not the case. Only in certain kind
of market conditions is that going to be
applicable applicable for you to trade
from. Uh but anyways,
the basic kind of concepts of trading
with value, right? So VWAP, volume
[clears throat] profile, tpo, uh they
all work the same way in the sense that
price will be pulled towards the mean.
So the point of control or VWOP, right?
That's fair value. Um and then the edges
of value are usually going to be your
trade locations more often than not,
right? So um inside of value, value area
low will be support. Inside of value,
value high will be resistance, right?
And then outside of value, it's the
opposite. So value area high is holding
as resistance as price trades outside of
value, right? All right. And then
conversely, when you see a shift back
inside of value, um the opposite occurs,
right? So, we were bullish against this
level holding as support value or high
as support. We trade back inside of
value, right? It now becomes resistance
on a retest and it will attempt to trade
to the other side of value or in this
case it traded just into VWOP. We got
one more retest to value area high again
holding as resistance because we are
inside of value. And then at that point,
u new VWOP starts, but it does end up
trading into value area low before it
continues to trade lower, right?
Um
okay so kind of common misconceptions
and kind of the ways you can actually go
about trading this right [clears throat]
common misconception people like to get
confused. So when VWAP is trending,
right? So of course there's times VWOP
is flat. There's times when it's it's
sloped down, right? It develops with
price. That's why we call it a
developing value area DVA, right? So
when it is developing, right, as price
goes up, price goes down, price stays
flat. It's going to follow price, right?
It develops with price. So with that
being said, there's times when know for
example here, right? When we talk about
like this. So so value area low support
inside of value outside of value, right?
it it holds resistance, right? So that
obviously becomes applicable when it's
trending, right? So when VWAP starts to
trend with price, this is what we'd call
price being imbalance down against DVA
or imbalance down against value. So
when that's the case, right, you're not
looking to trade off of the second
standard deviation because the condition
is bearish, right? We're not looking to
trade two standard deviations away from
the mean when price is rejecting value
area low as resistance, right? It's
rejecting value. So, it's imbalance down
against value, right? The only time you
can kind of get into taking a trade-off
of these is when the condition is
rotational within value, right? And
you're you're playing mean reversion
plays back towards the mean, right? So,
if you're trading up into here, right?
And it's not establishing acceptance
above value, then you can took the play
trades back towards the mean, right? So,
like I [clears throat] said, that's
going to be your main use case of using
the second standard deviation. Of
course, there's times when it is
imbalanced down like this and we're
trending against it. You can see that
momentum starts to round out here and we
start to range and then we see a move
back into value and that would be where
you'd want to get long and target the
other side of value because you're
expecting it to move to the other side
just via kind of basic AMT rules, right?
You're expecting a move from value area
low to value area high. Often called a
traversal of value, right? And you play
to the other side and then at that point
the condition stays rotational here
until we trade against value. So, um,
little recap, you're able to look
through kind of what happened. Let's
look at the following day here. So once
VWOP starts, you know, the bracket's
really small. It's a bit less usable at
that point because the margin between,
you know, value low to VWOP to value
high is way smaller as opposed to when
the bracket starts to get bigger here,
right? So if we were to look at today
as a good example, right? Let's just see
kind of what happened. So for example,
we were bullish against value. We're
holding above it, though nothing has
really happened. We haven't established
any momentum. We get this move down.
Looks like we took out the lows. We then
accept back within value, right? And
then we become imbalanced up. Just move
this over a little bit.
Becomes imbalanced up against value,
right? It becomes bullish against it. So
we were imbalanced down here. So value
area low is resistance. We trade back
inside, right? We then hold above value
area high, right? So now we're bullish
against it. So that means that the
second standard deviation is not a trade
location, right? Because we're not
rotational within value, right? So you
can see that's kind of where it did top
and react here. But that's because it
started to round out that that bullish
momentum started to round out here. We
took out the high and then you see the
reversion back into price, right? A mean
reverts at the VWAP. We get another kind
of larger retest and just deviated value
area high, right? And then you get the
move through value, right? So again, a
sequence of bearish acceptance within
value bullish. We hold above value high.
That's a that's a bullish shift. So now
we're bullish again. We trade into the
second standard deviation. Though you
don't really want to trade here, right?
Right? I mean, you could off of the
sweep here, you know, expecting that
momentum is slowed down. We're going to
revisit value, that kind of thing. But
just trading off of the condition here,
nothing has changed yet until we get
back into value. And then at that point,
you're expecting the move through value,
which we get to VWOP, which is your mean
reversion. Okay? That's that's your
mean, right? And then we get a larger
move back up and then it, you know,
trades to value lows, right? And then
even from there could have been a long
there back to VWOP, right? Being that
price is going to often revisit that
area. Uh and then from there again an
example of
[clears throat] using your standard
deviations right so we are rotational
here until we truly break down from
value. So, like I said, you know,
bullish condition, we see acceptance, we
move through value, and then at that
point, unless we truly broke down here,
right, we're still rotational here,
unless you start to see this and we
start to trend, right? Being that we
held here, you can see this is where you
could play a mean reversion play back to
VWOP, right? So, we could have longed
here back to VWOP, right? We we traded
to value low again, being that it's
going to hold this support because we're
within value. We trade up to VWOP one
more time and then we get that
aggressive move lower, right? So
uh take a look at this here right so
same thing uh much no much more
overextended from value at this point
but we cap there we're now bearish
against this level because we are
trending against VWOP we're imbalance
down against VWAP right you can see the
momentum starts to round out here so we
were very bearish obviously going lower
here starts to round out a little bit
you then see a move back within value
holds support right and you expect to
target the move through value so would
have been a good long there right and
then at that point it caps at value high
or almost tests it anyways. Takes out
these highs. Okay? And then you get a
move back to value low. And given the
the condition here, right, we're still
just rotational within value. We haven't
established a trend above here yet or
below here yet, right? So, you're going
to expect this to continue until
something changes. And you can see we
come back to value area low, right? So,
we just are playing rotations of value
and then we trade back up to value high.
And now we're just compressing at this
level, right? So, again, this works on
any any market. Doesn't matter what it
is. So again, I want to just draw this
one more time for simplicity sake. And
then we'll start to wrap this one up.
But again, here's your VWAP. Okay, value
high. Then we have value low. And then
I'll draw the second standard deviation
here. That's kind of hard to understand,
but hopefully you get the point. So when
price is rotational and we're doing more
of this, okay,
that's when you're going to look to use
the standard deviation to trade off of,
value high to trade off of, right? If
it's rotational, playing move to the
other side of value given this is a
rotational condition, right? Right? So,
you can target the mean for mean
reversion. You can target the other side
of value, etc. Those are going to be
your contextual targets. Um, you're only
going to use the second standard
deviation to trade more or less, right?
If if there's an aggressive trend, it's
not a trade location because you're
holding against value, right? So, that
would look like this, which is the
opposite. So, you don't want to trade
off of here. This is a really common
misconception with trading VWAP. Let me
just clear this one. It would look
something like this. So, say that here's
Let's draw this again. Say that this is
VWOP. Here's value high. Okay, here's
value low. Let's say that, you know,
price does something like this. Okay,
here's your second standard deviation.
Let's just say this continues to trend
higher. Ignore my horrible artwork, but
that's fine. Here's your second
deviation. Okay, and you're, you know,
you're holding above value here, right?
You're not trying to trade off of this,
right? The second standard deviation is
for fading moves back towards the mean
or fading to the other side of value,
right? playing rotations. If the market
is bullish against value here and you're
holding above value, why are you trying
to catch a short, right? You should be
trying to catch the pullbacks into
value, right? Until something changes,
right? And then maybe momentum rounds
out and then you start to see a move
back within value towards the mean or
other side of value, right? So, really
useful stuff. This is implemented in in
many different ways across many
different VWAPs and stuff within our
server. So, if you're interested in
learning, you know, how to do all of
this at a at a high level with kind of
deep comprehension and stuff, you're
welcome to join the server. Links within
the bio, guys. Have a good one.